good day happy Friday and welcome everyone
I'm Jack Van Horn from the University of
Virginia and I'm very proud to welcome you
to this edition of our 2022-2023 foundations
of biomedical data science seminar Series this
lecture series is supported by uva's integrated
translational Health Institute of Virginia the
UVA brain Institute the College of Arts and
Sciences the school of data science and through
a grant from the National Institutes of General
Medical Sciences since 2016-16 the foundations of
biomedical data science seminar Series has focused
on the use of data science methodologies
artificial intelligence deep learning and
statistical modeling as they pertain to differing
themes in the biomedical and Health Sciences
this year's theme is data science and the public
health consequences of the covid-19 pandemic
where every Friday we hear from leading thinkers
about the issues promise opportunities and hurdles
associated with understanding the secondary health
effects of covet 19. these health effects include
delayed Health checkups treatments mental
health drug abuse increased obesity obesity
and the long lingering health effects associated
with the SARS covid-19 virus indeed our 2022-2023
application cycle is now open and we strongly
encourage Junior faculty members working in areas
such as infectious disease epidemiology clinical
medicine population Health as well as data science
machine learning AI statistics and other relevant
domains to consider applying we believe this is an
exciting and engaging program where characterizing
the secondary health effects of covid-19
necessitates a unique quantitative approach
but also new multi-disciplinary collaborations
participants in the selected biomedical data
science Innovation lab program will leverage
these presentations as vital material for our
culminating in-person Grant project development
Workshop to be held at the lodge at St Edwards
Park in Seattle Washington in June of 2023.
today I am delighted to welcome not one
but two speakers Dr Olga brosnik and Asif
rizwan from the national heart lung and Blood
Institute at the National Institutes of Health
Dr brosnik is a data scientist who co-leads the
biodata Catalyst team and works on synthesizing
data science activities across nl88 excuse me
nhlbi following her mission to empower individuals
in communities with data and knowledge and
tools is a process of creating their health she
brings together a broad spectrum of disciplines
from computer science to transformative leadership
and trustworthy sustainable engagement
originally a computational physicist Olga
facilitated the adoption of innovative
approaches and biomedical Computing and
informatics collaborative Technologies data and
knowledge integration modeling and visualization
when there's a variety of inter-agency initiatives
and open science and Innovation Asif is a health
scientist administrator who actively manages NIH
research Awards which include genetics proteomic
metabolomic tools and systems biology approaches
is academic and research training have given him
a unique background with a wide diversity of
scientific disciplines including biomedical
engineering Diagnostics data science Health Equity
and Technology he also serves as a program staff
on initiatives to support whole genome sequencing
and other omic related data analyzes he serves as
program manager for NIH rad X Tech initiatives and
a dedicated Congressional appropriation to speed
innovation in the development commercialization
and implementation of Technologies for coveted
testing um in continuing with our 2022-2023
biomedical data science seminar series theme
um Olga is going to be presenting on data the
data science ecosystem of Bio the biodata Catalyst
uh Asif is going to be discussing trustworthy
inclusive and responsible AI you'll also discuss
synthetic data for biomedical research and we look
forward to a long conversation with each of them
um in the last 10 minutes or so of their
presentation as always we are streaming
this lecture live and for recording via YouTube
and if you are watching on YouTube thank you so
much for joining us also our specially selected
2022-2023 biomedical data science Innovation lab
participants and alumni are encouraged to
submit any questions they have via the chat
feature in their Zoom sessions I'll synthesize
these questions um and we'll help to ask them
on your behalf during the last 10 minutes
or so of the lecture and with that Olga and
Asif welcome we are so looking forward to
your presentation thank you so much Jack
I'm a little bit uh so I have two screens to
manage um thank you so much I'm totally thrilled
to be here both of my children went through
the experience of the University of Virginia
one in graduate school one in undergraduate as
an undergraduate and uh I'm totally thrilled to
be here and give back to the community so today
I will be talking about nhlpi biodata Catalyst
how we are prioritizing diversity and my first
question to you is why is diversity even important
I really am looking forward to your answers
because as innovators in this biomedical
Innovation lab you have ideas that we at NIH
may never have thought about I've been not
part of many Innovation labs in my life and I
know that ideas could be amazing ideas coming
from the slabs let me tell you just a few words
about NIH and nhlbi NIH which stands for the
National Institutes of Health an age mission is
to seek fundamental knowledge about the nature
and behavior of living system and the application
of that knowledge to enhance health plans on life
and reduce illness and disability NIH consists of
27 different institutes that focus on different
aspects of our health life stages like we have
Institute of Aging child health we have Institute
of cancer National Cancer Institute as if I
represent National heart land and Blood Institute
so mhobi preservation for data science and it
includes leveraging emerging opportunities in data
science to open New Frontiers in hlbs research
here is a little trick we love acronyms in the
federal government so hlbs stands for heart lung
blood and sleep research that nhlbis focused on
so visual for data science includes new
technologies from omics platform to high
throughput screening this potential of vast
amount of data to provide new insight into
preemption and precise treatment of
heartworm blood and sleep disorders
could be optimally assessed and
incorporated into clinical care
and Via seen how it is happening
and trying to help it we um focus
on Innovative approaches in integration analysis
and interpretation of data from multiple sources
and enable effective use of data to understand
biological social and behavioral determinants
Association which was hlbs health and
diseases and to improve patients outcomes
so my question to you again
I will really really appreciate your answer
answers if you want to make the best use of
data that we have right now haven't we have
enormous about the amount of data on different
aspects of our health our life our behaviors
what would you do what would be your Solutions
so NHL Beyond some years ago
created an hlbi biodata catalyst
as one solution to this problem with a problem
it is the cloud-based ecosystem providing tools
applications and workflows in secure workspaces
I want to say that that uh by data Catalyst
Consortium has a statement of conduct which says
that it is dedicated to providing higher estimates
free experience for everyone which means inclusion
of everyone of different genders gender identities
age disability physical appearance and so on
inclusion and diversity come very close together
so the explosion of clinical and research date
in recent years has led to a need for cloud
storage and Analysis it's obvious that you cannot
download petabytes of data on your laptop and then
crunch the numbers there so that's why that's
why we established a cloud platform for devs
so the mission of biodata catalyst is
to develop and integrate Advanced cyber
infrastructure Leading Edge tools and fair
data to support the nhlbi research community
and the vision is to be a Community Driven
ecosystem implementing data science solution
to democratize data in computational
access to Advanced hlbs so times as
you can see people and Technology are combined
in this ecosystem and that makes it powerful
so one more acronyms that I used on the previous
screen uh is square data principles I'm sure most
of you know about them but I thought it
would be it would be fair to explain what
prayer means Fair principles include findable
accessible interoperable and reusable data if
you cannot find the data set it's very little
use to you and if you cannot access the same
so and if you cannot uh interoperate couple
of different platforms or tools to work with
the data that's obviously true and we want to
make very reusable because it's a very valuable
asset especially data coming from clinical
trials that sometimes cost millions of dollars
so biodata Catalyst ecosystem
consists of uh people
they bring in different data in this case uh that
shows on the picture genomics data clinical data
Imaging data and then in the biodata Catalyst you
can uh process this data store you can reprocess
here I want to emphasize that workflows are very
important for reproducibility of science it is a
big challenge in science to make it reproducible
so when we work with data it seems very simple
but even in the data world it's not so because
different people follow different uh different
workflows and different processes so a little bit
closer look at the same uh you can search data you
can create new cohorts for your studies combining
multiple studies you can reuse your workflow let's
say and explaining I I know maybe you know this
but workflow is a set of steps first you cleanse
the data then you combine it with something then
you uh process it with some specific tool and then
you want to remember how you did it because the
next person who comes in may not know what you did
so say the workflows actually enables reproducible
science which is a big advantage to this system
and um I will talk about other aspects
later but basically you can bring all
all your own tools and Publications and work in
a secure environment and apply different tools
and other applications we also
host uh data in by data catalyst
So currently about that data Catalyst
or we call it VGC as we love acronyms
um it caused several controlled and open data sets
and my today example since I don't have that much
time to talk about different examples I picked
the transformic for prescription for precision
medicine uh example to talk about diverse data
um but there are other data sets and different
studies and also um users of PDC can bring their
own data which gives you flexibility and you can
analyze co-analyzer with data hosted in BGC and so
on of course we have data use agreements data use
limitations and so on different RB policies and
guidelines we definitely have to comply with them
so let's talk about Transformers for precision
medicine Precision medicine is a program at NIH a
little bit more few words about NIH basically what
we do we have small comparatively small intramural
program where people do signs at NIH but majority
of our function goes to extramural researchers is
um and as I understood uh your
Innovation lab is funded by one of
the NIH Institute nigms natural National
Institute for General Medical Sciences
so the top map program um the part
of the sponsored by an hlbi provides
um aims to provide disease treatments tailored
to an individual's unique juice and environments
.map integrates whole genome sequencing and other
owners such as metabolomics epigenomics protein
RNA expression patterns with um database molecular
behavioral Imaging environmental and clinical data
um just a glimpse into top map data uh these are
on the left you see a whole genome sequencing wgs
stands for home genome sequencing and different
omnics are represented in the middle and the
number of publication Publications definitely
keeps growing since uh the beginning of top map
it has a different phenotypic data so phenotype
focus on this on this pie chart so shows that
there are data set focused on the data is focused
on blood diseases heart diseases lung diseases
this is dogmat ancestry and ethnicity
uh we usually have a problem that
um our data sets are mostly biased because
a majority of people have European ancestry
as you can see it is the case with top
math as well however the African ancestry
takes a large piece of this pie and so
does Hispanic and Latina population and
Asian ancestry is represented as well so even
though there is bias but there is definitely
a good good uh well represented diversity
this is a different uh representation of
basically the same uh the same point that
we have a number of diverse participants
um light blue represents Europeans red represents
African and uh just like green is Hispanic Asian
is in purple and there are also others that didn't
identify or were a mixture of different um phrases
so just to highlight several examples from
what has been achieved uh with top map data
I want to say that for example the
asthma region was identified in
Europeans and then uh ryokozo s p was
discovered only in African Americans
which emphasizes how important it is to know
the difference between different ancestors
also it turned out that normal lung
function reference is racial specific
this uh publication identified a causal variance
that showed that ancestry status almost entirely
accounted for the difference in white blood counts
between African Americans and European Americans
and also genetic mutation implementations used
for diagnosis or hypertrophic cardiomyopathy
discovered in Europeans post false positive
diagnostic results in African Americans
so we really need diversity to make sure that
everybody everybody receives receives good care
and positive outcomes from our treatments
so I'm coming back to the BDC ecosystem
um obviously to provide needs of
top map researchers uh we first
focused on different types of genome
tools and so the key Tools in BDC
ecosystem include genome-wide Association
strategy genetic variant colon structural
variant colon annotation Explorer topmath
imputation server and AI machine libraries
I wanted to give just one example
um recently had presentation from
the BDC fellows and this this example just
kind of highlighted the importance of BDC
um Jasmine omwani studied malaria in Ghana
population according to what she said uh
BDC was an incredible platform she got her
pipeline functional uh very quickly and was
able to access the data quickly it would
probably take months on a local machine
so bar data Catalyst has several
very interesting features first
of all it enables team collaboration
because it is at the foundation of BGC
it allows users to bring data tools and workflows
to the data it provides hundreds of optimized
Plug and Play tools to so researcher can focus
on their science and not technology you really
want to answer scientific questions and not to
figure out how to put two different tools together
it allows you to get more done in less time
it's faster computer in the cloud it supports
reproducible workflows provides support tutorials
and documentation to help users navigate the
system it also provides 500 in Cloud credits
to new users of the system who works on hard
lung blood and sleep research and it continues
to develop according to user Community needs
one program that I wanted to highlight
here which might be of interest to you
it is a BGC fellow program the benefit
for researcher is that it offers early
career researchers funds and for mobile and
Innovative research for biodata Catalyst it
is also magnification because it improves the
ecosystem you and which is used fellow feedback
we'll learn how to do business better how to
provide better environment for the scientists
it also provides engagement with Consortium
members other fellows and broader community
is the program provides cost for salary travel
training publication and Conference fees to a
maximum of currently 69 k if you would like more
information here is a website that you could check
we are very focused again speaking about people's
side of digital signs I want to mention that we
are very focused on training collaborations
and being mindful about these collaborations
uh the summer Institute uh at the University
of Washington um introduced introduced
um geneticists to Modern methods of statistical
analysis and statisticians to the challenges posed
by some Modern genetic data um our current
um we are now establishing collaborations
with Atlanta University Center data science
initiative and Howard University which is our
local historically black University or College
if you are interested in exploring and learning
more about biodata Catalyst you can check out
Community hours community hours even though it
says hours you don't have to spend hours there
you can pick a topic of your interest and watch
um YouTube video about specific interests
of viewers for example on reproducible signs
we have YouTube channel just like you do where
we have our community hours Reflections from
fellows recording from different events
and workshops and how to's and tutorials
and of course we have newsletter that you can
receive electronically if you subscribe so all
these resources are available owned by data
Catalyst websites that I pointed to earlier
so coming back to my question about diversity
I really am looking forward to see your
um answers to this question but
for me it comes to the following
we live in this amazing country called United
States of America where population is diverse in
so many different ways we have racial diversity
ethnic diversity we have diversity in education
um religions YouTube we have diversity
among different aspects and we want to
provide everyone with equal Health opportunity
we want to provide the basis for Health Equity
so diversity is very important in our
data sets and in our everyday life
and I am like welcoming your thoughts about
how we come even better to our diversity work
so biodata Catalyst prioritizes diversity in data
sets throughout Consortium collaboration
and in asking powerful scientific questions
this is the end of my talk and I want to express
my gratitude to nhlbi leadership to the BDC team
my nhlbi colleagues and all
of you for attention this
um this event thank you very much this is
my contact information if you want to send
email I'll follow them up with questions
I would be happy to answer thank you
thank you Olga I think we just kick it
off with Asif from now thank you oh okay
thank you very much
thank you Olga thank you
Jack let me share my slides
right
all right the title of my first talk is
just what the inclusive and responsible
AI for biomedical research I'm massive is one I'm
a program director at nhfbi in the blood division
Ai and machine learning have made positive impact
in machine learning algorithms develops for
disease Diagnostics prognosis drug Discovery
protein structure prediction Imaging patient
interaction healthcare administration and
for many other reasons AI can learn from from
from the features in the data Ai and machine
learning can help streamline clinical decision
for example Technologies such as Alpha phone can
predict protein structures with high precision
it can save a lot of time and resources for
research machine learning algorithms are
widely used in heart disease cancer detection
COPD asthma management sickle cell anemia pain
research and for many other research at
NIH and across many other federal agencies
machine learning and AI can keep us more precise
understanding of basic science how to design new
biomaterials patient management and overall
is helping health research and Healthcare
given um given the power of AI and ml it is
clear that the scientists have the desire
to engage with machine learning research for
instance there are close to 1500 NIH funded new
projects in machine learning and AI category
with a total of more than like 800 million
dollar in funding during the fiscal year 2020
and 2021 you can see the spending amount by
27 IC here ICN centers here such as NCI cancer
aging heart lung blood and sleep and other ICS
however although there is a rapid growth
and Adoption of machine learning the lack
of insights how exactly the machine Learning
Works has delayed the full scientific
understanding and also has led to distrust and
hesitation in using machine learning algorithm
some of the challenges are lack of transparency
limited data lack of explainability and
interpretability lack of inclusiveness
security concern and accountability concern
many agencies and institutes have started creating
guidelines to emphasize the role of trustworthy AI
machine learning subject matter
experts have raised this trust for
the topic at conferences Acro conferences
and workshops across NIH FDA Food and Drug
Administration National Institute of Standards
a technology anist and at many other places
machine learning and AI are by means
no by no means perfect there are many
concerns that must be addressed so to
build and to maintain public trust in
Ai and machine learning we need to create
and adopt the principle of trustworthy AI
U.S Department of Health and Human Service has
created a trustworthy AI playable they have
identified six key components number one fair and
impartial number two transparent and explainable
number three responsible and accountable number
four safe and secure number five privacy and the
last one robust and reliable so I will briefly
talk on all of this component on my next slides
we are an impartial AI models must make
predictions that do not introduce biases
into the model impartiality must be
considered throughout the entire model
developments which includes data collection
model model design testing and considering
social determinants of Health as a
factor for the machine learning model
machine learning outcome must be accurate with
all demographics for all race religion gender
a 2022 uh study a recent study uh uh tested
several different Ai and machine learning models
that can identify liver disease through blood test
that study found that the machine learning model
missed 44 percent liver disease cases for a woman
however the model only missed 23 percent cases for
men this is an example of inconsistency
in Modern Performance Based on gender
bias is present in the data can propagate ratio
and social preferences in the machine learning
model a study found that pulse oximeters made
mistakes when used on Asian Black and Hispanic
population machine learning algorithm that
were created by this pulse of signature data
might make wrong prediction many genomic studies
were done in the European population as always
has mentioned in her in the last talk so
this uh result may have limited utility
across population therefore we must establish
fair and impartial data sources and algorithms
transparency and explainable everyone involved
with the research with the data with the machine
learning research research should be properly
informed about how their data is being used
how the AI system makes it makes its
decision transparency is essential
for Regulatory Agencies such as FDA
to review and to approve the models
recently research investigated the association
between uh surgical surgical skill marking in
thermoscopic images and Diagnostics performance
of a deep learning neural network they found
that machine learning model classified images
with surgical skin marker so this is a mole if
there is surgical skin marker around the mole uh
the machine learning model uh like made mistakes
they did not pay uh attention to the right
features so so investigator could consider
developing an explainability method overall
uh explainability and transparency have many
potential application in understanding the
actual model and in understanding the biases
responsibility accountability so machine learning
policies should Define who is responsible for all
aspects of AI and machine learning this also
includes if a machine learning algorithm leads
to a bad outcome who is at fault the
researcher who created the technique
the business implementing the research
the doctor watching over the algorithm
the hospital is in the algorithm is anyone at
fault what what do you think this feel free to
write your comments in the chat researchers
should be transparent with their machine
learning model data sources methods results and
implementation of the model this also includes uh
like this also includes like you know
how how do you communicate mistakes
mistakes if a critical device decision there
should be a clear roles and responsibilities
in place to respond to the problem and
how we can prevent this from happening
Safety and Security machine learning
models can become useless if proper
security measures are not taken one
study found that a machine learning
model trained on data sets injected with even
0.1 percent noise could lead to a wrong outcome
when we consider like you know how much effort
and resources it takes to collect the data for
this model then we we must understand that like we
must make sure that AI systems are safe and secure
this should be a top priority to
ensure trustworthy machine learning
privacy are are patient providing the data
being adequately informed and giving consent
does the data contain pii
Phi or other sensitive data
has that has the data been de-identified
or encrypted the Privacy rights of all
individuals and entities and groups should
be preserved and maintained data Collective
from individuals should not be used for anything
more than what it was authorized for this has been
a major cause of cause for concern in machine
learning research Studies have shown that
even data that has been de-identified there
are some technique to re-identify that
data so this is a big risk for privacy
robust robustness and reliability AI system should
have the ability to learn from humans and other
systems and produce accurate and reliable
outputs consistent with the original design
the model must work in the real world it's it
must produce accurate and reliable outputs if
a researcher is not careful a good AI machine
learning model that works in a test population
that works in in a lab might be inaccurate when
using real people data with a variety of symptoms
and issues is the training that accurate
represents is the sharing data uh the real
representative of the real world settings and
is the training data free of noise and outliers
these are the some of the key questions that
we should all consider are the models output
sensitive to small variation in the inputs how do
you how do you manage new versions of AI Solutions
NIH and many other agencies have started pushing a
lot of attention to this challenge of trustworthy
or AI energy aim ahead program was created to
Advance Health Equity and diversity programs
like aim ahead will increase the representation
of underrepresented communities by building
partnership NIH bridge to AI is is another program
that aims to develop ethically Source deficits for
AI projects there are many other activities
across NIH such as metric Medical Imaging and
data Resource Center in 3C National covet cohort
collaborative and all the mentioned lhsbi Biore
Catalyst a cloud ecosystem so all these programs
try to address some aspects of trustworthy AI
they all want to address the harmful
potential biases in the data and in the models
uh so there is there is also a lot of
potential room to continue working towards
the trust for the AI initiatives
across uh all the federal agencies
this summer uh one of our intern Eric Rosie who
was a uh odss coding It Forward summer fellow
that is also a good program for any any grad any
students who are interested to work in the NIH
so please check that out in the in the odss and
coding It Forward website so Eric analyzed uh
publicly available image data to find NIH projects
with a focus on the trustworthy AI principle
he conducted a keyword analysis as shown in
the in table one these are the keywords that's
the that's the category accountable impartial
privacy reliable security secure and transparent
um he counted the number of projects in interest
in each of these trust or the category as shown
in table two overall he found that only 11
percent of machine learning projects between
2019 and 2021 mentioned trustworthy AI keywords
so it shows that there are rooms for growth
in this talk uh we tried to Define certain
principles as modeled by uh Health and
Human Service guidelines we also showed relevant
examples where these principles could be addressed
as you can see from the figure the input
from all stakeholders uh like you know uh
patients caregivers researchers clinicians
communities uh they all can provide feedback
on existing and emerging machine learning tools
to identify the gaps in the trustworthy principle
most importantly the adoption of these principles
must be widespread researcher from all different
backgrounds companies government organization
clinicians patients we must all adopt and
advocate for trustworthy AI principles to make
sure that AI systems are truly helping individuals
trustworthy inclusive responsible
AI will benefit all individuals
it will prevent both intentional and unintentional
harms and solve our mission in enhancing health
so I would like to acknowledge
our initial bi leadership uh
initial be a data science
Coordinating Committee odss leadership
and also most of the most of the uh items
that I presented today were prepared by
Eric Rossi who as I mentioned he was a Civic
digital fellow so please check that out this
is that is a good opportunity for students
to work in an age for 10 weeks in the summer
all right uh I will uh since we don't
have much time I'll jump into my next talk
um synthetic Health Data for biomedical research
what is synthetic data synthetic Health Data is an
inexpensive alternative to real-wall data Centric
data maintains the statistical property of the
original data it is normally free of restriction
that comes with Phi projected health information
and pii personally identifiable information
synthetic data can meet the principle of fair
findability accessibility interoperability
and reusability and elsi ethical legal and
social implication uh I've also mentioned
that uh in her talk on the biological catalyst
so simply there's a uh can meet those principles
synthetic data can be structured or unstructured
they can be generated from existing real-wall
data or can be new there are many techniques to
develop synthetic data generative adversarial
networks is one of the best known deep
learning based model to General synthetic data
why we need synthetic data we have seen many
breakthrough in data-driven technology in health
research this type of Technology depends
on large amounts of Quality Health Data
however to access and to use Health Data are often
challenging sometimes we need many actually not
sometimes all the time we need many different
types of regulatory approval to access the data
many Health Data can have a limited sharing
concerns especially if the data
comes from vulnerable population
a lot of Health Data have location information
addresses Phi pii sometimes it is difficult
to fully de-identify this type of Health Data
sometimes actual data can be very small actual
data may not be representative of the scope and
the long which you don't know over the time like
you know you're getting data from multiple years
uh longitudinal aspects of the population sensory
data can be used uh to create a bigger Health data
sets which can be then which can then be used
to develop machine learning models and tools
data for training and research sometimes it is
challenging for training mpis from a especially
from a limited resource settings where they
may lack the support and the resources for it
is for using actual Health Data Centric
data can help in this situation as well
right so these are uh some of the selected
publication on synthetic Health Data the
use of synthetic data have increased a lot
recently it is estimated that by 2030 most
of the data used in machine learning
will be since artificially generated
some of the recent Publications have shown the use
of techniques of synthetic health and biomedical
data synthetic patient data Centric data in
machine learning for medicine and Healthcare
synthetic genomic data publication has shown that
synthetic Health data sets are not significantly
different from original data in terms of feature
distribution feature dependencies and sensitivity
overall the risk of generating
and using synthetic data is low
some of the Health and Human Service supported
activities there are there are actually several
ongoing research on synthetic Health Data
NIH ncats National Center for advancing
translational science they have a centralized
secure data ecosystem to study covet 19.
this is known as n3c National covet code
collaborative m3c collects data from the
electronics health records and this data ecosystem
has a synthetic data that were generated from
the actual patient data citizen scientists can
access this synthetic Health Data onc office of
national coordinator for health information
technology onc initiated a synthetic Health
Data generation projects in 2019 with a support
from Pico TF patient-centered outcome research
trust fund this project wanted to produce they
produced a lot of high quality synthetic Health
Data by Cynthia data generator they generated
several synthetic data module modules such as
sepsis leukemia opioids use pediatric population
yeah you can you can go to their website and cash
website and once your website for more up-to-date
information and the status of these projects
there have been a steady increase in the number
of application with synthetic data at NIH
uh we found that the total number of
applications that were that came to
an edge and total number of applications that
were funded both of these numbers are going up
over the years quality of application
have increased has increased as well
so the timing appears to be right for research
for synthetic data in biomedical research
here are some examples of research Awards
funded by initial bi these are all publicly
available information at nihreporter.gov
website so please go to their website if
you are if you are interested to know more
to know more about all of this synthetic
data that is funding in one application
uh Pi is developing a privacy uh privacy
uh preserving synthetic data sets for clinical
decision another application is using synthetic
data to understand the impact of uh physician
learning on the safety of cardiovascular devices
another Pi is using a synthetic segmentation
to develop a models of ecocardiographic image
in conclusion uh this is my last slide uh
synthetic can maximize access while protecting
the data privacy and sharing restriction
same thing that I can reduce uh cost it
can eliminate many legal restrictions of data
sharing synthetic data can um uh like you know
improve teaching and training opportunities
for Next Generation biomedical scientists
sensory data can be used for testing theories
and algorithm they can also provide big data for
genetics and genome-wide Association study they
can allow creation of population specific test
data set especially specifically for vulnerable
population or diverse population it can reduce
bias and will allow training and Ai and machine
learning models for targeted intervention as well
so I would like to acknowledge initial
bi leadership uh initial bi data science
Coordination Committee their leadership and also
I would like to acknowledge he is also a program
director at Citrus nhpi and he is working
heavily on scientific data at the initial bi
all right I will stop sharing my slides now
and I can take any questions great Asif and
Olga thank you so much to the both of you
for providing these wonderful overviews of
what's going on at uh nhlbi and these various
programs um going on with AI and ml applications
um just uh some great resources in there thank
you so much for sharing all those one of the
things which I learned Olga from your presentation
which I just didn't fully appreciate was that uh
nhlbi actually has a silent S at the end with
uh sleep research I did not know that and uh
so that may be very interesting for people who
are interested in uh like doing sleep research
um that maybe na nhlbi is the place to look for
that yes we have a sleep center right that's
fantastic well one of the things which is kind of
interesting about the um the Catalyst ecosystem is
you mentioned um harmonization which I think is
like one of the critical elements of this where
we have such a diversity of data um you want to
be able to make them play well with each other
and make them interoperable you know which is the
I and the fair principles and I'm curious about
the role of Standards or at least best practices
from the point of view of the Catalyst or your
point of view or from the nih's point of view
about why that might be important of course it is
important of course it is very important because
if we all follow different standards and uh the
joke was from my early years uh what is good about
standards there are so many to choose from but if
but if we all follow different standards um like
you take an example not from the data world but
from the real when you go and travel to different
countries you have to bring this device that plugs
into different electric Outlets to make your
um to make your whatever electric devices you
brought with your work as the same with data
of course we follow different standards for
different reasons because people cannot also the
Anthology word was uh used to be only singular
now it's plural and we all use anthologies
because Anthology is supposed to be a concept
A specification of conceptualization but as we
know we cannot agree on religions we all follow
different paths in life and system on beliefs of
beliefs but uh there should be something common in
uh in all this so we can communicate to each other
now when we talk about the data standards the same
is true here when we bring um different data
from different standards and different ontology
we have to harmonize them we have to make sure
we have this uh device that plugs into the our
data system that transforms the data that we
collected according to one standard into a
different standard or different data model so um
uh there are a lot of efforts on standardizing
um many different data but at the same time
we do acknowledge that people use different
standards and when we come together we have to do
a lot of uh not a lot but hopefully not so many
transformations to make some point together which
is called harmonization of data as you mentioned
specific policies but I can definitely send you
everybody who is interested to visit odss website
data science audiences is our office of data
science strategy at NIH um that has all the policy
guidance on standards and um different aspects
different other aspects of data science that's
wonderful Olga and this kind of the the notion of
harmonization kind of leads me to a question for
Asif concerning you mentioned trustworthiness
in Ai and ml applications and I think you know
the how the data are harmonized kind of helps to
support the trustworthy nature of data and the
algorithms that one would want to apply on it and
it brings me to kind of this notion if you had the
figure that kind of showed a a series of things
about uh you know about robustness and privacy and
accountability and whatnot not it occurred to me
that a lot there's a huge balancing act that has
to go on to make all of that work so for example
you could have something that's really a robust
algorithm but it's just not explainable so you
could repeatably you know get the same answer all
the time but you have no idea why um in contrast
you may have fairness of the the data types that
are being uh included and very they could be very
diverse but on the other hand you have to balance
people's privacy and it has to be accountable
there needs to be accountability I'm curious about
how someone can help to keep that Balancing Act
you know keep all the plates spinning if it were
so so Jack like you know um
at this moment everyone has a
different definition of trustworthiness uh like
uh explainability fairness reliability privacy
safety responsibility so uh we hope people will
keep this in mind when they design their research
imagine all the researchers are hypothesis driven
right so you design an experiment you you get the
data and you analyze the data so if if we can at
least keep all this trustworthy principle in mind
you know then uh I I strongly believe uh it will
improve the trustworthy AI this data will be fed
into the model right so uh overall I think uh
yeah like uh we have to keep all these things
in mind and uh it will take some times like we
have been talking about cluster di for the last
several years uh but uh uh it is difficult it's
difficult to uh Implement all these principles
yeah that's the thing is that it seems like
there's sustainability and you know experiment
is not easy and some people don't like it they
don't want to hear about it especially if they're
hardcore data scientists uh which I understand
like you know sometimes it is not possible it
cannot explain each of the layer but uh but some
sort of explainability will be useful that is what
I'm trying to say so if you one thing that's kind
of wondering about is is this a potential role for
some of the synthetic data that you mentioned
as Eve could it help to uh bolster some of
the you know explainability robustness fairness
privacy you know obviously it there's no privacy
to necessarily be worried about but can this help
us to make sure that we can do that Balancing Act
it can help us to help Define standards and
help kind of build this little feedback loop
um to make sure that people um are comfortable
with what's Ai and ml have to offer us absolutely
absolutely yeah that is one of the big use of
that will be one of the big use of synthetic data
people can like you know develop new model they
can twist the data they will have access to the
data the problem with the Health Data the biggest
problem is that you need to have all this type of
regulatory approval IRB approval and some of the
data we just cannot share like so API developer
model based on the data we don't know what the
data where you know it's sometimes difficult
for others to verify the model so since we get a
differently can help us to spread the data share
the data use hackathon challenge price like you
know competition like so it will be much easier
definitely there's a big use of sensitive data
I think we've heard from some of the other NIH
um folks that we have had join us about various
uh challenges and hackathon type things and uh
there's some interesting challenges that actually
you can win and win prize money I'm curious if
there are any that you might uh point us to before
we leave today or you could share them with with
me and I can make sure that they get to our
audience members sure I I can we can share
that with you that'd be fantastic because one of
the things which I always enjoy about talking with
folks from the NIH is that they provide us with
these great big picture uh programs and ideas
and kind of where the NIH is going and inside of
all of that if you unpack it there's all these
little nuggets of amazing opportunities and I
want to make sure that uh our readers and our
future biomedical data science Innovation lab
participants have full access to those so they
can take advantage of them um so please yeah send
me anything that I might need to know with that
uh Olga and Asif thank you so much for sharing uh
these great programs and and these uh things that
are happening at the level of the NIH in terms
of the national heart lung and blood and Sleep
Institute and we are super excited to uh kind of
follow up on some of these and uh with that said
thank you again and everyone have a wonderful
weekend thank you Jack it's been a privilege to